all these chars were obviously blown up
by Israel Hamas didn't do that to any of
them Hamas didn't rape or abuse any
women and it's all of course
they did really yes okay get the only
one that's talking bull crap is you you
flipping scum dirt bag double standard
hypocritical
fool there is not a better time to
support Muslim owned businesses anaka is
one of them simple modest and elegant by
simple elegant modest wear online at
anaka inspired your ultimate destination
for Quality modest clothing from open AB
bias to close the buyers discover a Cate
discover a created selection that
defines Timeless Styles they also sell
th for brothers and at and hijabs
brother and sisters support and buy your
loved ones elegant modest clothing now
check them out in the link in the
description box
below brothers and sisters and dear
friends brother basam Yu uh went back to
um P Morgan show and there is a couple
of points I mean I'll say anywhere from
s to 10 points uh where uh he made some
very interesting points and we're just
going to dissect them inshallah so we're
going to watch for oursel uh and you can
just see pce Morgan at hypocrisy and
double standards once again I think
Basim brother Basim just held himself
back because I would have called him out
for every single one of them let's start
off with this one inshallah and let's
see what we can
learn April 1970 there was an attack of
an Egyptian School in the middle of
Delta 100 kilometers from where my
parents were born it's called on that
day Israel bombed a school killing 30
students now what was so interesting
going back in history this is this was
the headline of the New York Times in
the day and it was says 30 pupils in
Egypt said to die in rap said to Die the
passive voice which rate who did the
rate we don't know and then you read it
this is mhid Yan he was the defense
minister of Israel at the time he said
um the target had been a military
structure that had been photographed
from Air both before and after the raid
what could have happened here was
irresponsibility of high orders from the
Egyptians that they set aside a floor or
some room for civilian purposes such as
a school now do you believe that so you
can see that this was what 30 40 years
ago the headlines are still the same
dehumanizing the Palestinians or the
Egyptians and the same propaganda the
same things not blaming theel but rather
blaming others that was beautifully
shown by Brother Bassam that this is
continuous it's just a propaganda
machine that is backfiring now has been
doing on October the 7th what Hezbollah
did within hours of October the 7th and
carried on to the next year what the
hoies have done a lot of it orchestrated
by doubtless the Iranian regime do you
categorize that as resistance as freedom
fighting or are the elements of all
those groups who are genuinely terrorist
in their thinking oh you know um
someone's terrorist is other ones how
you categorize how I categorize it I
mean like I'm an American citizen of
course I don't want to come back and
find the FBI reading my house so yes of
course the terrorist do you believe that
well at the advice of my lawyer I would
say I don't think you'd be banned from
going back to America you know what
happened to Scott Ritter he was the
former un inspector of nuclear weapon
Iraq he convicted ped yeah but like he
when he was raided a few month ago it
was because he was talking against
Israel um ASA wi Stanley he was a
British journalist in London and his
house was raided just last week because
he talked about Israel and this is
actually Fierce what I like about you is
that you are a fierce Warrior against
cancel culture right if you cancel
people for their opinion we're not
living in a anym right so for example
you have Robert Salah who was the coach
of the NFL Jets he was like a small Leon
Lebanese flag and he was he was I mean I
don't know it's it's I came to America
and I was so happy that I can speak
about anyone I want and then suddenly
it's like oh we can do whatever you want
unless if it's like it is I mean it's
now here's a very interesting point they
talk about freedom of speech the fact
that he cannot answered that directly
and I'm an Evidence to that because I
cannot if he asked me that question
again what do you think I'm going to
answer I'm going to say what yeah I mean
I might choose to just be silent on this
matter yeah TR you there is no damn
freedom of speech you flipping Liars you
cowards you double stand Hypocrites you
don't believe in freedom of speech just
like Tommy Robinson the scumbag the
farite this Israeli Shield dirt bag yeah
who said he would go and join the Israel
army coward go and having five star
holiday send his little foot solders the
burn hotels down here you can clearly
see they don't believe in freedom speech
cuz I went into this event we was needly
getting killed why cuz they don't
believe in freedom speech the fact that
basam cannot even actively say that say
are they Freedom Fighters are they are
they are they the t-word you can't see
it and then basam I don't know why he
said that he's like oh you know you're
an advocate of council culture there was
a doctor who was a he was a GP yes
practitioner yes he lost his job because
of P Morgan so please B
um stuck on him but anyways Israel here
on the America yeah and yet uh you have
Israel having a crazy control on the
political apparatus whether in America
or in here I mean 13 out of 25 of the
labor cabinet here are funded by uh
Israel lobbies 126 out of 355 MPS are
funded by Israel I mean out of those 13
members of cabinet is the prime minister
himself his counselor his Deputy the
Home Secretary the foreign secretary and
the Secretary of the Treasury which who
oversees the uh arms U shipments to
Israel so I I I don't understand
why I mean I think we should talk about
that more about anything because that is
actually what gives Israel the cover for
what they're doing the I mean my take on
Israel's government is that Netanyahu to
get back into Power aligned himself how
convenient do you see how he just
quickly changed the topic do you see
that this look Israel owns America they
own UK they own them they talk about
islamization of the Britain and us you
are owned by Israel you are owned they
are everywhere the zionists are
everywhere and they are controlling
these MPS to senators in America APAC
and swiftly just changed the topic the
world is waking up let's carry
on land you want that's not why the UN
was form that's not why the security
Council was when you heard that Sina the
Hamas leader had been killed what were
your feelings about that well when I
heard he was killed of course like I
mean it was uh it was this is something
that was actually like oh wow that's
actually he survived all that but it I
think it was a huge mistake by the
Israelis to release the footage because
now he's an icon right is
well I mean again someone's serious
someone hero right right you was l a
piece of wood at them of course the
biggest mistake they made because they
did not know who they were fighting the
biggest mistake they made and the whole
world forget Muslims
non-muslims have seen sinir as a hero
that's what they've seen it you go on
Twitter you name it wherever the guy is
seen as a hero because they're asking
which of the western leaders would ever
go to the front line and fight none of
them none of them so a lot of people are
saying hold on a second what he done
these accusations of hiding behind human
uh human Shields and hostages and run
away with the money or whatever was all
what a big fat lie a big fat lie in the
western world have seen it next one care
about what I genuinely care about which
is trying to work out what the world
should think about this what is the
correct proportional response from
either side to any of the things that
have happened and it is I think it is
morally complex you find it morally more
straightforward I find it complicated
and I've wrestled with how I should
think about this I've G on a bit of a
journey no it doesn't mean that for
example I would find common ground with
you about the way the Palestinian people
have been treated for many decades I do
think it's been a form of occupation I
form of yeah not not an occupation
fullblown OCC as I said to Israelis when
they come on I don't know how you can
argue but it's an occupation I know you
moved out in 2005 but the reality is
once this war started off they didn't
move out well once they formally moved
out you basically you went out of the
room and you locked the room and you
basically control the perimeter I was
about to say after October the 8 when
they began to turn off the water supply
the food supply the power and so on it
was quite clear they still wield power
was going on since so I'm AG with you
know you know you know I'm I'm agre with
what I'm saying is clearly that is a
form of occupation an occupation it's
say it's a form of terrorism okay I take
that point let's call it an occupation
and it has to end and in my view I've
always hoped and believed there should
be a two-state solution do you believe
that is even remotely achievable now I
don't know because the thing is you
created a m you completely destroyed all
kinds of you say me what do you mean no
no no not do you see how long it took
him to utter the words after one year or
should we say God do year it is AR it's
an occupation it's a form of occupation
how he was d d diluting it trying his
best and finally he was after he was
cornered he was that yeah it's a form of
um
occupation this is what we're talking
about double standards and bias he will
not say the same thing about Russia he
will not let's carry on two sided this
but there are two sides no yes but one
side of you're too one-sided and
understand why you know your wife has
family in Gaza I get it right you're
going to be one-sided that's why I've
asked you at the start of the interview
when you look back over since 1948 do
you find anything to criticize on your
side and your inability to articulate
any response to that mean makes me think
you are too one-sided do you accept that
if I met Mike Tyson on the streets and I
kicked him and he responded by kicking
me in the face killing me yes I did but
like he has a Leal weapon his hands
Israel is 100 a thousand times stronger
and they have the hold of to support all
of the money his feel might something if
you had taken a thousands of people and
you gone to Mike Tyson's house and you
committed atrocities on his extended
family and friends raping them and
killing them and saing people alive well
I know you don't believe there's any
sexual abuse well there was sexual abuse
we can talk about that well we will come
to that but I think it's in argument
it's been investigated by the United
Nations EST
well I've had journalists who I respect
more than any have you read the report
there is indisputable evidence of sex of
okay let's talk about that when it comes
we will I'm we agree to differ I'm sure
but my point is I believe it has been
unbelievable it is absolutely
unbelievable number one he's talking
about oh you're very two-sided you're
very one-sided when it comes to Russia
and Ukraine you are categorically when
mean destroyed you you are very
one-sided when it comes to Russia and
Ukraine you don't have no maybe the
possibility is cut for yeah no Russia's
wrong why don't you do the same here why
you why are you not the same here cuz
you can collect see and what the what
the Zionist entity has been doing for
far longer far worse but you are saying
you're two-sided you're onesided when it
comes to Russia not only that you talk
the M example cannot make this stuff up
I'm just the of these people only Allah
subhana is going to take them to account
that's why I say to people
Muslims day of judgment is a graduation
day for us for the for the Z for the
Zionist yes it's a day of Doom for the
Palestinians day of graduation they're
going to see all the oppressors you
think Allah's going to let them go Allah
says do you really think Allah says do
you think I am unaware of what the evil
doers do I only delay them for a day
that their eyes will stare in horror
he's talking about Michael Jackson he
goes p goes imagine Michael Jackson and
his family got this this this this this
this this that is the example of the
Palestinians so look how you're seeing
if M Tyson went through he's talking
about October 7 because that's when he
was born the flipping he's one
years old that's when he's born he's
giving this example but we're seeing
Mike Tyson going through that his family
being killed and this that's the
Palestinians not vice versa you clown
let's carry on not much
left yeah people we saw I I know what
I've SE and of course like as a matter
of fact I've seen many of them yes it's
terrible okay but so my point is if you
did all that to M's family and then he
I'm hang but if he if he did all that
and then he punched you in the face and
killed you would you feel that was
justified no but the thing is no s sir
sir you're trying to you're trying to
back you're trying no that's not the
wrong said like me and my mental man is
much stronger than me I I'm not going to
show up with like th person so if you
want to do the analogy you need to
modify the analogy again and uh the
thing is um I think it's like we always
ask what Israel should do but we never
ask what should the Palestinians do
because I mean I know that there's like
really great examples I mean there are
some peaceful examples there's a
beautiful boy called Mido he's 19 years
old he was an he's an exchange student
in Texas and uh he was moved from one
safe Zone to the other and he ended up
into a safe Zone and he was farming he
had a beautiful beautiful garden and he
was farming he was blogging about it his
mom died with because of lack of
medicine but he continued to farm you
know what happened to him he was killed
in air strike you ask me about the
Nelson Mandela and there home calleded
abuta he was he was inspired by the
Civil Rights moves and the anti- aparte
movement in South Africa and he toured
the churches and the schools and the
colleges in the United States and he
came back and Israel hit him in an air
strike killing five of his family
including his son and he was injured uh
if if Palestinians March they they get
killed if they throw a stone at the tank
they get killed if they if they sit at
home quietly someone will come in and
take their home away and they kill them
if someone just like picking up alliv
they will kill him so what would and I
don't know like it sounds to know what
you're doing your construction like I'm
justifying October 7th right no I going
to put words in your mouth it sounds to
me like you're saying what else did you
expect yeah what else do you expect if
you treat people like anal they would
behave like animals do you accept they
behave like animals yeah some of them
did yes some of them 3,00 of them there
you go there you go you cannot make this
stuff up the far right and Piers Morgan
he leans to the right they think that
Islam is taking over Europe we haven't
gone to anyone's houses expelled them
took over their country we have nothing
them and they are panicking and want us
out just imagine guys they are panicking
because their churches have tur into
mosc CU they don't go church and we
Muslims are practicing they are
panicking because of that just imagine
if we did 5% of what the Zionist on
Israel is doing in the UK these guys
would pick up arms and Slaughter us one
by one you see the hypocrisy when they
fear we are about to take over fear
there's nothing there to be we just
practicing our faith you're not going
churches so going mosque they they are
doing all kinds of stuff imagine if what
Israel does they would do far worse but
look at the poy there we go few more
Clips inah Palestine and they talk like
what would happen now what we get three
things the story of they decapitated
babies that was not true good so why did
didn't the Western media refute it why
didn't they ref it very quickly really
yes but how many times you said how many
times the Western media has used that
media until today Mike Johnson the
speaker of the house is still repeating
it until now Benjamin I know I know but
it was it has been discounted by the
media no not really not really not
really not really and it didn't and in
the discounted refuting and I think when
you have an apology or it has to be if I
was accused of saying I never said it
you said no I didn't say it you said you
said it came to me as a revelation that
I read about 40 kill 40 murdered babies
some of them are decapitated yeah maybe
which were early Report with Collins
yeah right which were early reports
turned out not to be true I know but
like but you understand the shock the
initial shock that made the public turn
a Blind Eye of what's Happening like I
mean if if I was like a European like my
I would throw back at you best than this
I don't know if you've seen all the
GoPro camera footage from hamat that
they broadcast to the world but I have
seen a lot of it and I have them I've
seen so so I think splitting hairs which
is what I would call it over the nature
of the depravity given the way that they
openly boasted the whole thing of
beheaded babies Etc was false but they
still propagate that narrative you know
why so that they can justify to the
people the people come say oh they've
done this of course no to them it's fine
they are looking for an excuse to do and
guess what they are going to do this
atrocities in Palestine regardless it's
just so you the viewer can be like they
did that to the babies H okay you know
what I'm going to have to turn a blind
eye to the retaliation that's one case
let's go to the other case of the grape
the grape yes if you know what I'm
talking about if there's any subst
substantial evidence on that between you
don't believe any women were sexually
abused okay let's talk about that but
but before that like I mean I just want
to just mention something about the
because that's important this is the
pictures is this burn out G after yes
this is the right and then we are we
should believe that Hamas went in with
AK-47 and caus the kind of them have you
seen the footage of them actually going
car by car doing that yeah but they
didn't this how do you know how many
they did does this look like 47 like
AK-47 thing uh looks like a bunch of
cars are being set on fire yeah yeah set
on fire okay this and then a few like I
know your argument is's ready to do
about themselves this is pictures for
something called the highway of death
from Iraq this is the same thing this is
Apaches these are Apaches right so this
is actually cars but have you seen the
footage of Hamas going car to car yeah
yeah killing them with machine and
setting fire to the cars yeah but that
is not the that is exact how yeah that
is that is like a an Apache these are
apach it's also the look of a car that's
been set on fire yeah but that doesn't
doesn't that doesn't C you're surmising
you're guessing no I'm not guessing why
are you trying to excuse what Hamas did
one of them is but I'm not I'm not
excusing I'm I'm talking about facts AR
facts this is just you saying look at
these pictures look at those at least at
least have you seen many burned out cars
in your life I have really and I have
two I in the revolution I had many yeah
but that's they didn't like that but
this is Apaches always burnt out cars so
many cars were that's yeah there were a
lot they went cars cars car they
literally stopping cars interesting yes
why wouldn't you believe it they wanted
us to believe that they wanted to show
the world that I mean you can't make
this up man he is outright rejecting the
heret their own Israeli newspaper the
IDF soldiers saying that they were given
the Hannibal directive meaning you take
everybody out the Israelis killed their
own soldiers their own civilians a woman
said who they were um um shelling the
houses they didn't have the they didn't
have the tools ham don't have the tools
to do that the lady say very clearly it
was their own fire he cannot accept it
cannot he's clearly showing him examples
of Apache what he does the remin is now
he's trying to say the Hamas went
where's the clipse of Hamas going on as
far as I know I haven't seen any yes
they're going and setting fire to that
many cars get the hell out of here man
yeah we're going to do two more Clips in
we're done talk about your claim that
you don't think any women were sexually
abused yes well the times of London
which is a right leaning newspaper
talked about the uh uh the UN report and
they said prila Patton who confirmed
Israeli authorities were unable to
provide much of the evidence that the
political leaders had insistently
existed in all the Hamas video footage
patents team had watched and all the
photographs they had seen there were no
depiction of rape we heard the leading
Israeli dark web researcher to look for
evidence of those images including
footage deleted from public sources none
could be found and patent said the first
letter that IED from the government
Israel talked about hundreds of
thousands of cases of brutal sexual
violence perpetrated against men women
and children I have not found anything
of that that the only report all these
chars were obviously blown up by Israel
Hamas didn't do that to any of them
Hamas didn't rape or abuse any women and
it's all of course they did
really yes okay you know it in your
heart you know I think so you don't want
to conceed an inch I understand why
because you think that actually the
bigger picture is Israel behaved like
this for so long towards the
Palestinians with their
occupation on camer you think it
diminishes your argument if you give an
inch to any of this stuff my point to
you it would actually I think it would
strengthen you not diminish you if you
were able to get L the only one that's
talking bull crap is you you flipping
scum dirt bag double standard
hypocritical fool you are that's why in
the whole world knows what kind of a
clown you are okay there is no evidence
for the babies there's no evidence for
the grape there's no evidence for Hamas
killing 1200 he lies lies lies lies
you're a hypocrite that's what you are
brother and sisters alhamdulillah I
don't think anyone should ever go to PS
TR again it's been done us this guy's an
absolute clown he has nothing else to
look look for look forward in life and
he only does the this you know
sensationalism that's what I'm going to
say in hope you guys enjoy the videos
and may Allah carry exposing them to the
whole which they are